how do you describe what you work on
when somebody asks
well I tell them that I'm a development
of psychologist but my interests also
cover Behavior genetics and evolutionary
psychology and I'm passionate about
twins because twin studies are simple
and very elegant way of combining all
three developmental psychology Behavior
genetics evolutionary psychology
different levels of analysis and
application
but also I'm a twin myself and so I
really think that when you're personally
invested in something you have greater
um interest and passion for the topic
and so my whole career I like into a
candy store I've just had a wonderful
ride and the ride is continuing that's
how I feel when I get to speak to anyone
from the EP world or the behavioral
genetics world or the sex research world
it's uh it's it's the absolute most fun
uh William Costello the guy that's doing
all of this stuff on incels at the
moment famously keeps on reminding me
that research is me search it's a little
bit different for him doing it on in
sales and do you doing it on twins given
that you're a twin I don't know what it
says about William given that that's
what he's studying
um what is the evolutionary psychology
angle of uh twin research I can see how
behavioral genetics comes in you know
we're splitting apart genetically and
environmentally what the contributing
factors are uh but I I'm less sure about
about the others right so one of the
you know very provocative theories that
was launched was kinship genetic theory
by William Hamilton who asserted that we
feel greater cooperation altruism
investment in people with whom we share
higher degrees with genetic relatedness
we don't consciously do the calculations
in our head but we behave as though we
do and so I've always known for years
that identical twins are more
cooperative
closer socially than fraternal twins are
on average and so I thought that this
was another level of analysis that I
could bring to twin studies because many
people say Well they're they're closer
because they look alike and people
encourage it but I don't believe that's
the case because behavior is not built
on appear as behavior is built on the
brain and so I always felt there was
some deeper level to this and so I've
been able to use twins I've been able to
use unrelated look-alikes I've been able
to use Virtual twins many many types of
relationships that vary in genetics and
in environmental connectedness and the
findings are are beautiful because they
really Converge on the same thing you
know I remember when I was doing my
doctoral dissertation my first major
study
and I use 7 to 11 year old children
Twins and what I did was I put them into
a puzzle completion situation a kind of
semi-naturalistic study where they all
completed the same puzzle under the
exact same circumstances with the exact
same instructions
and without a word for me and I kept
their mothers out of there
the identical twins just did this
orchestrated dance beautifully
coordinated there was little rough play
everybody was very cooperative and they
were very successful at puzzle
completion
but the fraternal twins on the other
hand tended to grab different pieces of
the puzzle to their side of the table
and work on it independently and the
whole thing looked like a mess and there
were lots of elbow Jabs and snatching of
pieces and so that really told me that
twins can tell us so much just by being
themselves
what is your explanation for why
identical twins and fraternal twins had
that difference for the people that
don't understand am I writing saying
that fraternal twins are essentially
just simultaneously born brothers and
sisters that's correct identical twins
result when a single fertilized egg
divides between the first and 14th day
of conception whereas fraternal twins
result when a mother releases two eggs
at the same time separately fertilized
by two sperm and so the kids share 50 of
their genes on average by descent which
is exactly the same as ordinary siblings
so I think that what is going on here
Chris is that identical twins who have
the same genes are responding to the
world the same way they have similar
temperaments they process information
the same way and so all of those
ingredients allow them to work more
cooperatively in a joint situation
whereas fraternal twins bring very
different interests and understanding
and abilities to a particular task I can
tell you that I have a fraternal twin
sister and in a puzzle completion task
of kids we've been at each other's
throats we had very different
understandings and ways of doing things
and we still do we're close sisters I
think a lot of siblings get closer as
they age but nevertheless as children we
would have been deaf on the competitive
side I wonder whether teams it would
very much depend on what the activity is
that you're doing but I can imagine some
activities in which you want someone
that's very similar to you but in other
activities you might actually want
someone who has a different skill set
you want to be the analytical one you
want them to be the creative one you
want to be the slightly more risk-averse
one you want them to be the slightly
more adventurous one so I imagine that
depending on what the task is at hand
you could have scenarios in which being
identical twins would be an advantage or
sometimes a disadvantage yes I think
that's right for example if you're a
very skilled say at
coming up with great ideas but you don't
know how to put them into play you might
want somebody who's more analytical more
statistical minded to really complement
you and so to that degree somebody a
little different would be helpful but
identical twins would probably just pick
a topic or pick an area where they both
excelled and they do very well at it one
area I'm really fascinated is Twins and
sports and it is amazing to see these
matched levels of elite athletes you
know it's extraordinary one person wins
an Olympic event but even more
extraordinary when the other one comes
in second how is this possible part of
it is because of the way their bodies
are built their similar motivations
there's similar interests and the fact
that in many cases a single a victory
for one is a victory for both and it's
hard to get your head around that kind
of selflessness
but I've heard it repeated so many times
what about that what about the degree of
emotional connection between identical
twins I mean there's uh tales as old as
time about they've got secret languages
and they can mind read and do stuff like
that
um but
have you found uh comparing it with
normal siblings and fraternal twins is
there an extra degree of connectivity of
emotional investment of kinship as would
have been predicted by that theory
I think there's no question that there
is an emotional connection that goes far
beyond any kind of relationship in fact
I would assert that the identical twin
bond is closer than any other
relationship even more than mothers with
children yes and I would I say that
because
I have a study on the loss of a twin on
bereavement and I wanted to understand
two things do identical twins grieve
more than fraternal twins mirroring what
you see in their relationships and is
there something unique about twin loss
and of course this was all framed by
evolutionary theory in particular
kinship genetics and I did find that
identical twins grieved more for their
code twin than they did it for any of
the loss of any other relative whether
it was a mother a father a non-twin
sibling
a grandparent an aunt or Uncle of course
when you get to those
you know second degree relatives the the
genetic relatedness dips down I'm
guessing that's the same for a son or a
daughter as well then
yes yes but well let me Backtrack on
that I have very few Sons and Daughters
very few twins lost children for which
I'm very grateful but that would be
theoretically it would be a fascinating
comparison because with identical twins
you share all your genes with children
only 50 whereas fraternal twins you
share half on average with your twin and
you share 50 percent for sure with your
child so I would expect much greater
variability among the fraternals
very interesting very interesting but I
really hope I never get to do that
comparison because I don't want anyone
to lose a child
I one of the other very interesting
things that I learned about when looking
through your research is that there are
times when a mother will release two
eggs
and will have multiple sexual partners
within that uh pregnancy window within
that fertility window and end up with
like half half twins like what what are
they called well the medical term for
that is super fee condated twins which
means that because she had two eggs
released and she had two different
partners each partner got to one egg in
that four day fertilization window and
the children are really genetic have
siblings but I regard them as a
legitimate pair of twins because this
could come out naturally and it can also
come about through artificial
reproductive assistance you know as you
know and I've told you I have a book
that's coming out August 8th called gay
fathers twin Sons the citizenship case
that captured the world and this is a
case where two gay fathers who were very
much in love with each other and married
decided to raise a family and so they
contacted a donor and a surrogate and
they each provided sperm to fertilize
these eggs and it turned out that the
top two embryos were each uh insept each
created by one father and those are the
ones they implanted so they replay a
naturally occurring situation
tell us that story well what happened
was there was a young man named Andrew
from the United States who decided to
get a master's degree at Tel Aviv
University and then he met another young
man ilad and they fell in love and
married in Canada in 2010. Tel Aviv Tel
Aviv isn't uh fantastic for trying to
get your gay wedding across the line not
really no in fact
in fact I will recognize gay marriage
but they won't allow it in their country
if you marry elsewhere it's recognized
at any rate they moved to Canada because
marriage gay marriage was allowed there
in 2010 and Andrew also had dual
citizenship in 2016 they decided to have
a family and that's when they gave birth
these beautiful boys Aiden and Ethan
and the problem became when the boys
were four months old and they decided to
move to Los Angeles and when they tried
to get the boys the passports at the
Consulate in Toronto they were just hit
with a a number of very rude and
intimate questions such as where do
these children come from who's the
father of this one who's the father of
that one intimate details that they had
no plans to reveal not even to their
parents the only ones who knew the DNA
lab and the surrogate beyond that nobody
knew the relationship of the kids so now
their genetic learnings are all hanging
out on the clothesline everybody knows
and so the upshot was that they issued a
passport to the little boy who had who's
created with a sperm from the American
father and a tourist visa to the other
one
and so this threatened to tell their
family apart tourist visas are good for
about six months they are renewable but
it was a travel situation so when they
did come to the U.S it was about
2017-2018 and that was when when former
president Trump issued these bans on
Muslim immigration so all the
immigration attorneys were at the
airports taking care of these cases but
they did find a wonderful group in New
York called immigration equality lawyers
that are very concerned with gay couples
HIV infected individuals other
minorities and they work pro bono on
behalf of these couples and Andrew and
Allah's case came about at the perfect
moment because they already had three
other couples trans and National who had
children outside the U.S but Chris twins
capture attention and this case really
got into the media because the idea of
separating two little boys who were born
four months apart is unconscionable
and and that was a real threat to the
family so the case was the family's name
DeVos Banks versus the U.S state
department and Rex Tillerson who was
then Secretary of State later Mike
Pompeo it was a very high profile case
it almost reached the Supreme Court
it took four years to resolve there were
moments when the government appealed you
have an appeal window of 60 days and
they would Appeal on the 59th day after
the Circuit Court ruled in favor of the
family
eventually the case settled no more
appeals and now they're living out here
in California
I can't tell you what a lovely family
there are and all you see when you look
at them are two really devoted parents
and two very happy children that's it
you don't see anything else
wow what a story how much of this do you
think
is uh concealed homophobia from uh
organizations that maybe and then I
guess actually a combination of
concealed homophobia and concealed
islamophobia uh intersectionally
combining to to create this
I I think that is certainly one of the
factors and I think whether you're a
homophobic or not if you just simply
disagree with the idea of it then I
think that that can play a role sorry
maybe homophobia might be the wrong the
wrong term though that just
there's there's less preference given
it's not like you need to discriminate
against but it's a slippery slope from
what is the treatment the same I'm going
to guess that it would be treating
somebody different on the basis of their
sexual orientation probably that's like
a a rough uh definition of homophobia so
it probably is it probably meets the
meets the criteria not quite the same as
going out of your way to call somebody a
slur but you know if you're not treating
them the same way that you would do as a
heterosexual couple or a couple that are
both from a European country or whatever
um yeah maybe maybe it does meet the
criteria yeah so at any rate I think
that's really plays into it and then
there's another element that I noticed
that one of the lawyers brought to my
attention and that is that the
government just seems in some ways to
make things difficult
I don't know why but they just seem to
make things difficult for these families
who just simply want to lead their lives
and so many politicians say Families
First and yet what about this family
and the wonderful thing about this case
was it did settle in favor of the family
and it has been helpful to Future
Families the Foreign Affairs manual
which is what is relied upon in the
consulates was modified
because of this and it's still the case
that officers have some measure of
discretion in interpreting some of these
guidelines and rules but nevertheless
um it's it's gone far and these two
fathers could have taken an easy way out
they could have gotten a green card for
the child they wouldn't have had any
publicity
but they were both very eager to make a
statement
and to leave some kind of lasting change
in society
they both had difficult times growing up
as gay men as gay teenagers they both
and so they know what it was like to
suffer and to stay strong and to make a
difference and so that was an attitude
They Carried with them into this issue
as well and and I I think they're
terrific I mean they're just terrific
right now they're they're over in Europe
having a vacation they're doing what all
families do in fact one of them said to
me
we're boring I said all we do is we take
our kids to Disneyland we watch Netflix
we go to you know the market and you
know we're just boring people just that
we happen to be two gay guys and and
they're right they are boring but I love
them I am very very glad that you've
managed to find such an interesting
story and uh was it three identical
strangers you know that that managed to
do something very similar with regards
to just captivating people's attention
he said it earlier on there's something
about
twins especially identical twins and
triplets that are just you know so so
captivating one of the things that you
brought up earlier on that's still
playing on my mind was
you mentioned uh the uh kinship genetics
prediction uh the the closer you are
genetically related to somebody the more
you should care the more that you would
be invested
how is it that twins know that they're
twins
in this case well that's a very good
question and I think they know when they
can see the other one
looking like them or even if they in the
fraternal twins you know there's someone
they've grown up with they've been in
the house now in evolutionary psychology
there are two cues that have been talked
about in terms of sibling uh relatedness
knowledge of a sibling is one of these
the Western Mark effect because this is
my favorite
um I wasn't gonna go there but we can go
there later because I think that's
really fascinating I have talked about
that and I'm going to tell you some
stuff that's going to startle you but
all right let me just go with this for a
moment so so the two cues have been
talked about in terms of sibling
knowledge knowledge of a sibling is
maternal uh Association so if you see
another baby with your mom you figure
that's a relationship to you and the
amount of co-residents so if you live
with a child another kid that means that
that's probably yours that's interesting
but it's not enough because most
identical and fraternal twins live at
home with same mom same dad same house
and yet we still have these differences
in social relatedness between the
identicals and the fraternals nobody
teaches them that so I think that it's
recognizing similarities and and it goes
beyond just the physical feature because
as I told you earlier I do studies of
unrelated look-alikes who look as alike
as identical twins and they are nowhere
as alike in personality and very few of
them develop close relationships that
are lasting just to interject there what
that would prove is that the reason that
identical twins are the same is not
because people treat them the same yes
but right because they evoke similar
treatment from others so see I'm sort of
turning the process around I do think
people treat identical twins more alike
but it's because they evoke similar
reactions from people and we call that
evocative Gene environment correlation
in Behavior genetics that's what it's
called
so at any rate I think that with
identical twins whether raised apart or
raised together they perceive certain
similarities of themselves that draw
them together beyond their appearance
it's their mannerisms their interests
their temperaments all those kinds of
things
I I've seen close relationships evolved
in no time I worked for nine years on
the Minnesota study of twins raised
apart and I could see these things
evolving very quickly between Twins who
recently met and I actually have done
demonstrated this quantitatively I had
identical and fraternal twins reared
apart
tell me how they felt when they first
met how they feel now in terms of
closeness and their initial feelings of
familiarity and current familiarity
the identical twins were significantly
higher on most of those than the
fraternal twins but an even more
revealing question that I asked which
I'm so grateful I put in was I asked all
the twins
how do you feel in terms of closeness of
familiarity to the adopted sibling you
were raised with in your home
very few said very close very very few
and that's rather counterintuitive you
think well I should feel closer to the
people I was raised with it's not so
it's just not something uh so what's
this uh counters a little bit is the
theory that it's just to do with seeing
your mother raise somebody it's just to
do with co-residency during the that
early years window because if it was the
case then the way that you look in terms
of similarity your personality type that
um level of resonance between you and
someone that you meet in later life
would have relatively limited impact
also one one thing I've been thinking
about you know in a a modern world where
we've got mirrors and we've got cameras
and we've got a phone that's got high
definition video recorder in it we see
ourselves but for almost all of human
history we didn't see ourselves right
how would we other people would be able
to say you look like them what about
what about lakes and ponds you could
look in there and kind of it wouldn't be
as sharp but you still have a sense of
what you look like and I know that some
of the some of the older cultures had
very shiny glass or metal where they
would look so it's not like today but
you certainly could get a sense of of
what you look like now I wanted to talk
about
um
the thing you mentioned before so the
Western Mark effect all right so that is
very very fascinating and I've I've not
documented this but I have noticed that
when identical twins are raised together
and both are gay they're almost never
each other's Partners in fact they have
relationships outside the home virtually
all the time and that could be a result
of you know familiarity breeds contempt
if you want to call it that
but there have been there was a pair of
identical twin men raised apart
that we studied at the University of
Minnesota and when they met they became
each other's lovers
now it's only one case I went back and
looked at the biographical material in
previous read apart twin cases and there
were a couple of cases that kind of
hinted at that sort of a relationship so
I wonder if it works the same way no
one's really ever looked at that because
the percentage of identical twins and
fraternals raised apart as relatively
small but you could probably do it with
siblings now there is a concept in the
adoption world called genetic sexual
attraction and it's been talked about
mostly with mothers and sons who reunite
and fathers and daughters and it's not
even that they necessarily
have intercourse with each other but
this mother described this feeling she
just wanted this close physical contact
and sometimes this does go into sexual
relationships it can but it doesn't
necessarily have to now where am I going
with this because I've documented five
or six cases of male female twins who've
been separated at Birth and who meet and
marry
and they describe a fierce attraction
probably based on the similarities they
perceive in one another and the way that
their relatedness is discovered is
because they usually have a child with a
genetic defect because remember that
every parent carries a lethal recessive
and
if you marry a sibling or you have you
know with two siblings carry the same
legal recessive the chance of a child
would be 25
if that couple got together so at any
rate
it's devastating of course but some
couples split up some don't it's very
very interesting and I also along those
lines noticed that when we had
separated male female twins in our lab
in Minnesota there was absolutely
flirtation going on
there's no question about it
wow okay so here's a question for you
what does the state think about
accidental incest
you know I don't know the answer to that
question but because some of these
couples are allowed to marry and I don't
think that they've been from this
country most of them have been from
Europe
and as far as I know no one has forced
them to separate if they separate it's
it's their own choice
isn't that interesting that we we almost
carve out a exception for the fact that
we know there is a very small cohort but
not insignificant of twins raised apart
for one reason or another
fraternal twins because that that's such
a shame I was thinking one of the things
I wish that you'd been able to work out
would have been
um sexual aversion or an increase in the
western Mark effect
if there was such a thing as
identical twins that were different
sexes
um it would be oh if they were raised if
they're raised together I bet that's
right but these are twins raised apart
they're the attraction comes in now
I think that that is something we have
to worry about and some countries have
started worrying about this because now
you know with all the sperm donors
creating so many hundreds of children in
some cases you have to worry that if the
mothers live in the same local area
these kids may be about the same age and
so half siblings might get together and
they might be attracted to another
just the way that separated Twins and
siblings are what has been what have
been some of the craziest similarities
between Twins who have been raised apart
that you've found
yeah well I have to think about these
twins Oscar and Jack who had the most
amazing story Oscar they were born in
Trinidad to a Romanian Jewish father
and a woman from Nazi Germany Catholic
that they were born in 1933.
so Nazism was just sort of on the
horizon the marriage
failed and so one boy was raised in
Trinidad with the Jewish father the
other raised in Nazi Germany went to the
Hitler Youth and so when they met of
course they had very different political
and historical understandings but they
both read books back to front they both
used to wash their hands before and
after using the toilet they both thought
it was hysterical to sneezed loudly in
elevators and they both got very upset
if they were in a restaurant and there
was a a Vaz of flowers in the middle
blocking your view of the other person
they used to collect rubber bands around
their wrists I mean they had a lot of
these very odd idiosyncratic matches and
a lot of people think well it's
coincidence I don't think so I think
these are hard scientific data I
honestly do the trouble is you can't
start studying rubber band wearing
around across cases but what you can
study Chris is you can study the
frequency of these odd similarities in
identical versus fraternal and I can
tell you that we found them much more on
identicals than in fraternals in fact in
the Minnesota study we had one pair of
paternal twin men who both had 18
tattoos we counted them now I sorry at
this point we didn't look at the types
for the flowers were they women what
were they we didn't do that but we found
18.
and I actually have a paper that came
out earlier in 2022 in the in the
Premier issue of the Japanese Journal of
genetic of twin studies and my students
and I did this project where we looked
at the similarities in twins from the
Minnesota study and from previous and
past studies and of course when a
similarity is something like
um using Crest toothpaste I mean nobody
cares about that half the world uses
Crest toothpaste but we had a pair of
twins that used a rare Swedish brand
called batty makem and so you have to
wonder you know what attracts them to
this weird stuff so maybe they like to
do things differently or maybe they like
the taste who knows or maybe they have
this Affinity with Sweden but
the beauty of these kinds of things is
that they give you new hypotheses about
why you do what you do for example we
had a pair of paternal identical twin
males who both held the beer can of only
Budweiser with their pinky finger
underneath now why would you do that it
could be because your hand is made a
certain way or you worry about spilling
the beer and you want to be very secure
about it
you just like the way it feels something
like where you think it looks cool at
any rate it gives us new ways of
thinking about these kinds of things and
let's face it all of us have odd
behaviors that we do that we hope nobody
finds out about but I'm willing to bet
you that they're not just there because
they're there they're there because of
you because of the way your body and
your mind are constructed and you prefer
doing things that way than alternative
ways yeah I uh I fear that there's a
twin an unseen twin out there of me
doing all of the embarrassing that
I do private privately and letting other
people know about it
um I'm thinking about
what you spoke about there these things
seem relatively arbitrary what type of
car do you drive what sort of toothpaste
do you use how many tattoos have you got
but they're very discreet individual
examples that explain an entire Suite of
traits that somebody has right so as you
said with the can is it because it feels
good is it because that's the particular
size of your hand and the can slips out
you've got particularly small hands of
particularly big hands or whatever right
what it shows is a physical
manifestation that's very obvious about
uh that represents something that's
going on internally and sort of uh
biologically too
what it suggests is that if we were able
to visualize thoughts on some super
intelligent fancy fmri machine in 100
years time the texture of their mind is
probably likely to be similar the sorts
of ruminative thoughts that they would
have the things that they wish that
they'd said or didn't say the number of
words that they say per minute the
number of ums ears and likes that they
speak you know all of this stuff is
determined by a combination of your
physical attributes the morphology of
your mouth Etc but then also what's the
predisposition that you've got mentally
well sure I think that all comes into
play I absolutely do and and I'm not so
impressed as I said with the common
similarities it's the rare ones that I
find intriguing and those are the ones
we focus on and so for example we I did
something with names in that Japanese
Journal twins how often they they name
their children the same name and we
looked at the frequency of how often
names were that name in those years so
you know you can start to quantify some
of the stuff and get some very
interesting findings wasn't the was it
the gym twins there was some incredible
case yeah the gym twins did too
unfortunately both of them passed away
they're the ones who met at age 39 and
actually launched the Minnesota study
they lived only 40 miles apart in Ohio
and they used to bite their nails they
described a headache syndrome as someone
pounding on your head they used to
scatter love letters around the house to
their wives they had work woodworking
benches they drove the same kind of
light blue Chevrolet they vacationed
them the same three block strip of beach
in Florida amazing they'd ever met they
had they had numerous similarities and
they named their sons James Allen and
James Allen one Allen had a nail two
Wells one had one I know you can laugh
about that but why would you name what
goes into name picking obviously the
other partner has a say in this too but
maybe because they were first born Sons
they wanted to name their son after
their own name very traditional
and or maybe the name Allen
reminded them of somebody like the way
it sounded I don't know I'm just
throwing out ideas but it just gives you
a new and fresh way of thinking about
these things not just chalking it up to
random chance didn't they have something
to do with their marriages as well
yeah so this is interesting one of the
gym twins
married Betty and divorced her married
Linda divorced her married Sandy now the
other one also married
sand Sandy divorced her married Linda if
I were Linda I'd be a little nervous
because Betsy's coming around I don't
understand he came into the atmosphere
I'd probably go running
so interesting and again you know you
think about all of the different inputs
that we have on our behavior all of the
Myriad interactions we've had with the
world the books that we read especially
if we've been raised apart different
books that we read different whatever
whatever and yeah they read the same
they read similar books when they read
it apart well there we go but it's just
this it's this permanent gravitational
pull towards your predisposition I think
so you know we all have choices in life
and we live in most of us do live in in
communities and cities where there's
lots to choose from and yet there are
certain things we choose and certain
things we don't and I think that's why
identical twins are alike because they
pick and choose the same things that are
compatible with who they are and and the
Very again another kind of
counterintuitive but true finding is
that genetics genetic effects seem to go
up as we age and people think how can
that be it should be environment making
more of an impact but it isn't because
once you get away from home and you're
not under the thumb of mom and dad
anymore you're free to pick and choose
and that's why the early studies of
religious interest showed no genetic
effects because they were studying
children raised at home by their parents
so both twins had to do exactly what Mom
and Dad said but once they left the
house you began to see the genetic
effects kick in because then
they would gravitate towards similar
types of activities and really Express
themselves and sports participation
works the same way very little genetic
effect when you're young at home starts
to kick in when you become an adolescent
does a is it IQ is 0.8 by the end of
life pretty much
the heritability is about 80 75 to 80
percent yes which is another one that
shows increasing genetic effects as you
age because you're constantly refining
your interests your activities all that
sort of stuff that feeds into mental
skill but you would presume a lot of
people the behavioral genetics deniers
out there would say that all of the
different inputs you have your nutrition
your hydration the amount of vitamin D
that you've got where it is that you
live on the planet the kinds of things
you get exposed to you know all of these
are going to in their eyes it would
mediate
your ability to deploy your IQ and yet
behavioral genetics seems to rule all
well genetics no genetics does not say
it's completely genetic I mean there's
nothing is a correlation of one
I find the most fascinating thing is
that there's so much out there that can
make us different and yet identical
twins are still remarkably alike whether
they raise their part or raised together
but again you know you certainly with
nutrition I mean if one twin is exposed
to a condition another one isn't you
know there are cases where one had
coveted one didn't that sort of thing so
certainly with infections I mean there
are many things that can make you
different but it's not like it makes you
different than every way you might be
different in one area but very still
very similar in others I've also had the
opportunity to work with twins identical
female twins where one felt like a male
and actually went through surgical
reassignment to become a male and yet
the Twins were still remark will be
alike in every other way
except for this one fundamental
difference and what was so wonderful to
witness was just how welcoming the the
non-change twin was you know she wanted
her now brother to be happy and content
and the brother wasn't for many many
years
what about uh sort of psychopathologies
schizophrenia depression anxiety
alcoholism uh other sort of maladies
like that what what is the uh insights
that you've learned with regards to
Fraternal and identical twins
well identical twins are more likely to
match on all of those than fraternal
twins there's a genetic component that
virtually everything you rattled off
schizophrenia is about 40 to 50 percent
it's nowhere near one the one that the
only psychopathologist that's really the
strongest genetic effect I've seen is
autism at about 70 and that can also
vary depending on whether you use strict
or looser criteria but bipolar disorder
has a genetic effect dementia breast
cancer interestingly does not it's about
20 similarity in females wow so you
could have uh you could have identical
twins one of whom just get breast cancer
and one of whom doesn't yeah that's very
very interesting you know so there's and
see those cases are extremely
informative for the general public see a
lot of people think that twin research
is only for twins but it's a model for
looking at human behavior in general and
so you could look at a pair of identical
twins and so one has cancer one doesn't
why why what about the environment that
triggered it in one twin and not in the
other and that's really important
information by way of prevention
diabetes is another one
you know one twin has it it's about a 50
Match multiple sclerosis is another one
twins it's funny because identical twins
are so alike but they're less alike than
people think they are both are really
true I hate to say it but it is what
have you learned about
twins that are raised apart and BMI or
weight
yeah so it differs from males and
females the similarities higher for
males with females there are various
hormonal effects exercise diet so female
is a little bit more flexible in that
way but body mass index BMI does have a
genetic effect as does height and weight
separately yeah yeah it's um that was
one of the most interesting things that
I learned because a lot of the time and
this gets on to what is it that you call
it the gene environment covariance of
correlation correlation that's it
um that
in a household
let's say that you have identical twins
it is very difficult once both of those
twins are in that household to pass
apart what is the contributing factor of
the nurture element here and what is the
contributing factor of the nature
element here you see
fat parents with fat children and you
think that that's because of their
lifestyle you know look at look at this
but there's a huge genetic component to
people's weight and you don't know how I
had Robert Plowman on the show he told
me this really really great Insight I
can't forget he said he has a
predisposition to overeat he said he's a
secret fatty and what he means is that
he walks past a bakery and the smell of
bread to him is just so alluring and he
told me this thing and he said there are
many ways to get fat what he means by
that is there are unbelievable Suite of
different Roots towards uh being any
anything that you want right being
conscientious being industrious being
fat whatever it might be it may be that
your ghrelin release is uh higher than
typical that's the the hunger hormone
released in your stomach it might be
that you comfort eat because of the way
that your mental dysfunction is it may
be that you really don't like exercise
you you are low on energy it may be that
you know pick your Myriad of reasons of
how people can get gain weight so when
you look at
um people who do gain weight you presume
that it's all from the same route but
it's not necessarily it can come from
places it can come from multiple sources
of course and see that's the danger in
studying
intact nuclear families because you
can't separate out the genes and
environment they're all confounded you
know for example parents pass on both
genes and environments to their children
so if the parents are very bright
readers and the child is too how do you
know it's not the genes how do you know
it's not the reading experiences as some
combination of both so that's why you
have to apply these developmental
designs that separate them out so one
the very simple one is the classic twin
monopsychotic or identical twins versus
fraternal twins another are adoption
studies twins raised apart you want to
disentangle the genes of the environment
that's what you want to do many
developmental psychologists study
parents and children and they come to
the conclusions that it's environmental
influence but it's not it's all
confounded it would be as if I was sick
and I took drug a and Drug B and got
better how would I know which drug made
me better I wouldn't know see it's the
same exact thing you can't figure out
what's causing what the other
interesting thing I always think about
this is that
um because you have a predisposition
genetically to be interested in certain
things and to behave in particular ways
and your children will do too
Therefore your behavior which is
predisposed by your genetics and your
children's predisposition and the
environment that your behavior puts them
into all start to exaggerate each other
now this isn't to say that children are
one-to-one with their parents traits
that's not the way that it works but the
point being that
when you see particular outliers I have
a friend here in Austin Aubrey Marcus
the guy that found it on it I'm pretty
sure his father was
his
parenta is actual biological father was
some inventor guy his stepfather was a a
very very impressive businessman and
that was the person that raised him his
mother was a world champion tennis
player and he went on to sell this
business for half a billion dollars at
age 35. you go well it's not you've got
the genetic components you've got the
foundations here and then look at the
environment that you grew up in it's not
it's not a particular surprise that in
adulthood you had a very high bar for
yourself super conscientious very
industrious worked hard and succeeded
yeah I know that's surprising at all on
the other hand you know parents can have
two children who are extremely different
and one child might thrive in the
environment that's provided by the
parents and one child will absolutely
refuse to go into the family business so
siblings and family differ by a great
deal and and the home environment is not
the same for all children parents can
provide all the sports that commit you
want but one child May thrive on it one
child won't even go near it one child
may stay on the computer the whole night
and the other child won't go near it
it's everybody Fashions their own
environment you know within the setting
that they find themselves in it's not
there's so many there's so many majors
we could all be right universities
offered tons of different Majors but we
pick one or two that are interesting to
us and we we don't even consider the
other ones why is that
it's nothing and I I have no interest in
being a lawyer my sister my twin sister
is a lawyer but I have no interest in it
is there have you looked at anything to
do with birth order effect I know that
it's not strictly a twin uh relationship
the trouble with birth order is well you
can have birth order effects with twins
but if the parents treat the firstborn
one as the older that could have some
sort of an effect
with twins however you know if the Twins
were born in the cesarean section and
what happens to be a minute old and the
other I think to make a big deal over
that means nothing now the only way that
birth order can make an effect with
twins is if it's a vaginal delivery and
the firstborn has a much better
situation than the other because the
uterus changes with the birth of a baby
making it much more difficult for the
second child
so that child may have you know more
adverse influences as a young baby
provide and will need a little more
ketchup period so that's where birth
order plays a real role but in
C-sections it doesn't then and to see I
think that a lot of these birth order
studies with twins don't take that into
consideration just lump everybody
together and it's it's ridiculous is
there anything that you can learn from
triplets that you can't learn from twins
it depends on the configuration of
triplets if you had
trip was composed of an identical pair
and a fraternal
I love that kind of triplets and I've
worked with a couple of these because
what you find is that the identicals
tend to be really close and really
similar and the Fraternal feels like the
odd man out and I've seen that on many
many cases
if they're all identicals you know
I mean it's it's basically three pairs
of twins so you can match everybody up
every which way and if they're fraternal
you can certainly learn a lot too
but I think that the most interesting
one are same-sex we are two are
identical and one isn't and what I if I
had to devise an experiment just pick
one up I would never do this but I would
like triplets like that and I would give
away one of the identicals
more like The Identical that they
weren't raised with or the Fraternal and
I bet you know my money would be on the
identical
wow that would be so interesting yeah
I'm not saying anybody should ever do it
I don't think twins should be raised
apart so I want to be very clear on that
yeah what's the
um ethics or how do you feel when you
know you're observing a lot of these
situations and you have what you've
managed to identify in your opinion as
the closest human to human Bond on the
planet literally the closest that you
can feel to somebody else and then they
get raised apart so what what are your
um feelings on the the ethics and the
discomfort around that and then what
happens when twins meet for the first
time
well the ethics are very interesting and
in my 2021 book deliberately divided I
go into that a great deal and this goes
beyond three identical strangers it's a
really in-depth analysis of the Louise
wise adoption agency that had a
misguided view that identical twin
should be raised apart because they grew
up with their own identities
and then the secret study that followed
these children up until the age of 12
that telling them or their parents that
they had a twin
so
separating twins for that reason this
misguided developmental Theory I I think
is unconscionable now I will say that
sometimes twins get separated for more
legitimate reasons so maybe a mother
dies in childbirth or the family can't
afford to keep them but the Parents
separate them or the family separate
them with the children's best interests
and heart I'm still not condoning that
but I do think it's understandable
and twins have also gotten separated
through odd circumstances we had a pair
where the twin was visiting her
grandmother in mainland China and the
other twin was in Taiwan and because of
political developments they they were
raised apart she couldn't go back and be
reunited with her family the one from
mainland China so
these things can happen
now my perspective is that oh and also I
have the study on the twin children who
were separated indirectly through the
one child policy in China
and these are twins who are separated
partly sometimes because the mother
gives away one and keeps the other and
then maybe gives the other one away
later or they're brought together to an
orphanage and then somehow they're
separated because people don't realize
they're twins or whatever but my view
and the view of my colleagues who are in
this line of research we believe in
bringing twins together and we don't
believe in keeping them apart for
research reasons in Minnesota we would
sometimes encounter twins who'd never
met and we wouldn't keep in part you
know for research reasons yeah maybe you
want to separate them we would never do
that in fact we made an incentive of the
study to bring them together so they
could spend time together and we would
test them separately you know we told
them not to discuss the test while it
was still ongoing all that sort of thing
and they took it very seriously I have
no doubt about that but I'm I'm
completely against twins being raised
apart sometimes private adoptions happen
where a mother decides to keep one and
give away another one I mean I think
it's unfortunate these things happen but
I would be of the opinion to never
separate twins I I just don't think it's
right
I think it's it's a violation of a
Birthright
what is it like have you have you been
there when twins have met for the first
time I have I have it's amazing it's the
most wonderful experience you could ever
imagine and twins do different things
some jump up and down some hug and kiss
some just kind of look at each other
sometimes they they touch their face and
touch their twins face at the same time
but it's amazing it's sort of this
moment of out of control Glee and you
can't help but feel the same joy that
they're feeling after all most of these
people or adoptees who never look like
anybody who raised them and suddenly for
the first time they're meeting this
celebrated relative and identical or a
fraternal twin and it's a big deal it's
a very big deal I mean I sometimes say
to people what if you learned that you
had a long-lost cousin would you go look
for them well modest interest how about
an uncle or an aunt maybe parent
absolutely identical twin you bet
it's it's irresistible it's just
irresistible
why do you think it is that so many
people have a problem with behavioral
genetic explanations for the traits that
we have
when people hear the word genetics they
feel that whatever that trait is is
non-changeable and is set in stone and
that could not be further from the truth
behavior is after all the expression of
a gene in an environment and if you
modify the environment you can affect
the genetic expression I will say that
some traits are harder to change than
others but you can engineer an
environment you can work harder you can
get into training you're not stuck with
with things now for example we know the
divorce has a genetic component because
identical twins are more likely to
divorce both of them than fraternal
twins but your genes don't tell you to
divorce you make the decision maybe you
have a difficult personality or you're
very fussy about your partner or
whatever the reason is but you make the
choice your genes don't tell you what to
do you are the one in command
yeah I see a lot of this on the internet
um especially coming out of the dating
sphere the black pill and the incel
movement that William in particular
studies
um you know behavioral genetics to me
was just what it was the second most
fascinating thing that I learned about
after evolutionary psychology uh and I
adored looking at this
not necessarily a conflict but this
tension between uh my predisposition and
and the outcomes that I got what I had
the wrong in terms of raw materials and
then what I had in terms of environment
that impacted that but a lot of people
do get fatalistic after learning about
behavioral genetics they believe that
they have a very heavily capped ceiling
that it's it's this sort of
deterministic life that they're living
now I am doomed to be X or Y or Z yeah
no that's that's really not the case I
mean maybe you're doomed to have brown
eyes or hazel eyes and but even then you
can get colored lenses if you really
want to make the change but let's face
it I mean somebody who may be six feet
tall will probably never be chosen for
gymnastics there are certain limitations
but I think that's good to know that you
know it makes us
predisposed toward more realistic
decisions and lifestyle changes so I
think I think it's good if you know that
say your parents are alcoholics suppose
you learn that well you can use that
information you're not necessarily going
to be alcoholic but you might watch how
much you drink drink a little more
carefully things of that sort so I think
it's it's wonderful information that we
can all use
how do you conceptualize or explain to
people this relationship of genes and
environments when it comes to to
outcomes in life and and how that should
inform our Behavior and the way that we
sort of see ourselves and our efforts
well as exactly what I just said that
you can alter environments and affect
genetic expression I give examples of
things like that you know I'll tell you
the people who I find the most
intelligent about this are the parents
of fraternal twins and siblings they
know more about human behavior and have
a more reasonable view of it than my
colleagues many of my colleagues they
just know that what works for one child
doesn't necessarily work for another and
many of them went into parenting
thinking that everything was
environmental and they come out of it
with completely different ideas as do
reunited twins
I I interviewed every reunited twin in
the Louise wise adoption study and a lot
of them said that they really felt that
behavior was environmental but they'd
never met a twin before and suddenly
they're learning about themselves that
their behaviors are not just coming out
of nowhere but they coming at us
somewhere and it's it's a great
education it's just a great education
for them how much let me just mention I
I also did a book recently this year on
the twin children who survived the
Holocaust it's an annotated photograph
collection I think I told you about that
and um
these are the twins who are in the
mangle experiments in Ash with birkenau
in 1945 and I went with them to the 40th
anniversary reunion in 1985 and you know
why did these twins survive when some
other ones didn't it's an interesting
question luck had a role here too but a
sort of resilience and strength and the
twin Bond too the strength of that Bond
gave them each kind of a will to live
which was so important which non-twin
survivors didn't have
um the benefit of
um thinking about the uh parenting side
of this how much can rearing change a
child
well I can't give you a number but what
I can say is that I think parents have a
very important role and I think it's
different than how people conceptualize
it parents do not mold you into what you
are I regard parental responsibility as
being very sensitive to the child's
individual tastes temperaments likes
dislikes abilities and interests and I
think if parents can be attuned to that
and really help the child to become more
of who they are
and to maybe overcome some of their
drawbacks like shyness or timidity in
some situations then I think that's a
great responsibility you know it really
pained me when when parents when mothers
were still pregnant or enrolling their
children in these prenatal programs of
Education I mean it's ridiculous I think
that that good parenting is really
sensitivity to the child and being very
supportive and nurturing so I think
parenting makes a huge difference I
think children who grow up with
insensitive parents or multiple
caretakers who don't take the time to
really see what their interests are are
the ones who are not going to benefit
yeah Jeffrey Miller once tweeted that um
every parenting book combined is less
useful than one book on behavioral
genetics for parents to read I think
it's very well put I would agree with
that yeah it's it's just I try and look
back you know I'm an only child so I try
and reflect on my own life and I don't
have uh another uh an A B split test of
me to be able to look at to be able to
compare there's some parts of my
personality that I do see from my
parents
but there is so much that's different
like so much it's incredible and I would
say that my parents um predisposition in
terms of the way that they're set up and
the environment that I grew up in was
quite aligned I don't I don't think that
they um change themselves massively when
I was born obviously all children will
change parents it's a massive life life
switch
but yeah it's uh I love the idea of
helping a child to find out what is
their passion what is their calling what
it is that that aligns most uh with them
because
you know for an individual parent to try
and reverse engineer or to um prescribe
in advance uh I always you know the
classic story of the father that didn't
get picked for the football team so you
know my son he's going to be the
football player and he's two years old
throwing a football at Christmas and
stuff
um that prescriptive role in some
regards is good because it creates
guidelines that children can follow but
if you're continually having to reforce
your child to do that because all you
want to do is play music or Draw or
whatever
you're fighting a losing battle yeah yes
you are and that's why I think that
parents of fraternal twins and near and
age siblings are the ones that really
understand human development these
fraternal twins can be extremely
different my sister Knight went in very
very different directions I took ballet
she took drama lessons we went to
different schools different summer camps
that were more suited to what we wanted
and my parents were very good about that
they didn't force us to be together it
was easy because children in their own
way will tell you what's best for them
if parents only take the time to look
um that's a lovely insight and I think
when I first spoke to Plowman about this
as well he he
the sense that I got I'm not a parent
yet but the sense that I got from a
parent's perspective is that it
alleviates a lot of the pressure I think
that parents feel yes I think that
parents who are less well informed about
what parenting is all about feel they
have to do everything and if they just
relaxed a little bit and paid attention
and took the cues from the child I think
they'd be a lot better off and they'd be
much happier and more effective parents
yeah I know no uh poems about saying
that yeah I think so too
um and and there is you know in a
meritocracy uh if you are your successes
then it also means that you are your
losses too right and we know that people
have very different as soon as you take
the behavioral genetics pill like forget
equality of opportunity forget that
right way before equality of opportunity
is equality of genetics which is just
not it's not going to happen between
everybody so as soon as you take that
behavioral genetics red pill what you
realize is that largely your child's
outcomes in life are going to be
determined by the partner that you chose
to have them with right and you can do
things to improve that you can make the
quality of their life better but if
you're you know tiger momming your way
to hope that you can create 140 IQ child
you're going to be disappointed keep in
mind too though that suppose you've got
two parents who are very interested in
dancing or sports or something like that
they can have a child with absolutely no
interest in that whatsoever because the
genes reshuffle in every generation and
and then also what's popular in one
generation may not be popular in another
and even if a child has a certain
ability that aligns with that of the
parents there may be something else
that's that's grabbing everybody's
attention in the generation to which the
child was born so these things you know
have have all kinds of factors affecting
them
parents and children I think are
actually less alike than people think
they are we do see similarities
definitely but children are very
different and I think it's largely
because they they had they get different
swedes of genetics and they they're in
environments and generations where
things can be vastly different yeah I
think I'm really seeing this in my
generation so I would be pretty much
slap bang in the middle of the
Millennials and I would probably guess
that aside from some times when there's
been Global pandemics like the Spanish
flu or world wars or Genghis khans come
through or something that this block has
had from parent to child the largest
inflection point in terms of the
difference of environment that we found
ourselves in you know you have parents
that grew up without the internet
children so for me I was not internet
native but I think the internet would
have come online maybe when I was 11 or
12 something like that so I've got a
little bit of time before that and a
good bit of time before smartphones but
relatively digitally native but the
difference the difference in my my dad's
upbringing in the 60s and 70s and mine
in the 90s and the 2000s is is a
different universe so yeah you know even
if you have even if you were one to one
with your parents in terms of your
genetics look at how different all of
the different inputs are that you've got
the the opportunities that you have that
influences uh the the chance to actually
display this behavior in a completely
different way
yeah the differences are extraordinary
and they are there's no question about
it and um yeah we can't account for
everything but I think we can count
account for a lot you know what it makes
me think about I have a friend Johnny
that comes on the show quite regularly
and someone asked a question four or
five years ago on the show and they said
um if you could go to dinner with um
four people alive or dead who would it
be and you know you've got the the
typical idea of thinking about it would
be Mohammed Ali and would it be Socrates
and would it be Plato and would it be
Jesus and Johnny's answer was that he
would love to sit down with all four of
his great grandfathers because he thinks
that he would learn an awful lot more
about himself from sitting down with
them than he would yes and this is a
benefit that the internet has given us
that we can track our families in many
ways that other people never could and
there's a real interest in that now too
I regret the fact that I didn't ask my
grandfather more questions about his
coming over from Russia I think I would
have learned a lot but still there's
ways of tracking thing things and um and
many twins have found each other because
of the internet when I was in Minnesota
we thought that we had exhausted every
pair of weird apart twins in in
English-speaking countries and that was
so wrong it was so wrong so many have
met on the Internet by posting a video
not even knowing they were a twin just I
I studied a pair of twins born in South
Korea and one was raised in New Jersey
and one was raised in a very Posh French
suburb and the one from from New Jersey
moved to LA
was an aspiring actress put a video of
herself online a friend of the other
twin sought and said you look remarkably
similar and that's what led to their
reunion it's absolutely amazing and you
know this gets back again to something
we talked about a little earlier I think
the idea of finding someone that looks
so much like you or is so much like you
now there are websites for finding
people who look like you these unrelated
look-alikes and not only that there are
websites for finding a piece of art
sculpture a painting a drawing in a
museum that looks like you and we don't
go looking for something that looks
different than us children's
imaginations of friends were always for
someone similar and I think that's all
such fascinating and very revealing
information about human nature
people who see identical twins are
fascinated and I think the reason
they're fascinated is because
we all learn to expect individual
differences in behavior and appearance
and so we when we encounter identical
twins to look so different it challenges
our beliefs in the way that the world
works and it fascinates most of us but
it can still turn off some people who
are nevertheless intrigued some people
may say it's too much closeness too much
similarity takes away from individuality
but everybody is intrigued nevertheless
and I think that's why
whenever anything happens to identical
twins it's in the news I mean it's in
the news all the time
and I you know I get these cases and I
get context from journals all the time
that want commentaries on unusual cases
and in fact right now I'm working with
the Guinness World Records book on
compiling the update instead of twin
records which is a lot of fun did you
say that you've studied or managed to
try and track down every pair of
identical twins in the English-speaking
world
Minnesota study concluded we thought
that we had had every pair right Indians
being wrong
it was a very naive conclusion because
there were so many out there there were
so many people who don't know their
Twins and there were people who didn't
have the means to find out if they
suspected but now they do and there are
people out there fraternal twins who
will never find out because they don't
have the advantage of mistaken identity
so many twins meet I wouldn't say many
but a number meet because of mistaken
identity somebody confuses one for the
other
you know and then that's how it all
comes about but fraternal twins don't
have that advantage and so when I think
back to that Louise wise adoption study
of twin separated birth
virtually all those identicals met
through mistaken identity and the
fraternals did not and I wonder were
other fraternal twins out there who were
separated and will never ever know
and I think that's a shame it's got me
thinking uh this is only very
tangentially related to your work I've
been thinking for a little while about
interracial couples and then the
children that they have and I
I'm doing a study on that but keep going
okay all right so my bro science not
your real science we can get into that
in a second My Bro Science was I would
be very interested in looking at
parental
opinions and perspectives on race
relations
let's say that you have a a white mother
black father and then mixed race child
but you know the gene is relatively
dominant so it's going to be a dark
child so I would love to speak to the
mother and and work out what it's like
to be completely uninvested in racial
discrimination personally uninvested you
can altruistically be as invested as you
want and then immediately upon having a
child for this to change and he would be
the second one and this would be the
craziest one if you were able to have
the uh I can't remember what the name
was when you have two eggs that get
released and two sperm that go at the
same time
yeah but if you had that but those were
interracial that there was you had a
white and a black okay let me tell you
something I'm very interested in the
so-called biracial twins too and these
are fraternal twins that are born to
mixed race couples and I got interested
in this because in one of my classes I
had a pair of fraternal twins one looked
very Hispanic and one looked very
Caucasian and they did have a Caucasian
mother and Hispanic father
and they told me that their life
experiences were extremely different
despite being raised at home and in the
same communities that everybody thought
that the one who looked Hispanic was a
dumb one when in fact it was just the
other way around and so there have been
many more mixed-raised couples lately
and they have fraternal twins and so now
I've I've interviewed probably 10 15
couples because I want to understand the
different life experiences of the kids
and what the parenting challenges are
and I also am trying to get at the topic
of do you feel a greater kinship of the
kid that looks more like you racially
than the other one and that's a very
hard concept to get across I mean you
can't say who Do You Love More you can't
say that but I wonder if I can somehow
tease that out and maybe a less direct
way because it's an interesting question
and I also wonder if there is less
paternity uncertainty in mixed-aged
couples there might well be I don't
think anyone's ever looked at that but
that's something I can I can think about
at the same time but it's it's really
biracial comes from the press and the
media it's not a term that makes sense
to me because they're not biracial they
may look biracial but they're equally
biracial because they have the same
parents
okay I understand that
um what are the common criticisms that
you encounter around twin studies
whether it be methodology conclusions
pushback that sort of stuff what's most
common it's probably mostly
methodological people think that when
twins are
together they learn from each other
that sort of thing or they're not tested
separately and I think people some
people think that the conclusions are
overdrawn but I would argue that the
critics have not done the studies
themselves and they've probably never
encountered a pair of twins I mean so so
many people who have these hard opinions
don't have the experience to really make
the appropriate judgments and you know
and also so many studies that have used
different populations different subject
pools different protocols converge on
the same conclusions in in my book 2012
where I give a whole overview of born
together rear to Park which is the
Minnesota study
I reprint from one of our papers a graph
showing the IQ correlation from four or
five different read apart twin studies
one in England one in Denmark one in the
US One in Sweden different populations
different time points different
protocols and they all Converge on the
same basic conclusion about 0.75 is the
genetic effect and you it's rare to get
that kind of repetition replication I
should say in the behavioral sciences
it's a very robust finding yeah I was
going to say you know for the people who
like to throw the term replication
crisis around and and point the finger
at fields of psychology and social
sciences which is very Justified the two
places that you really shouldn't be
pointing the finger a behavioral
genetics and evolutionary psychology
because both of those lots of repetition
there and lots of converging evidence
and and I I I really love that because
it's different methodologies and
different people but even if you go
outside of behavior genetics and
evolutionary psychology you can see
studies done in Social psychological
theories and they come out with the same
thing but their interpretations are
different there's a wonderful study done
in the 50s where they simply asked twins
you know who would you miss most in the
event of death twin mother and while
there was some little variation against
my studies it was basically very
remarkable that genetic relatedness was
more aligned with higher levels of grief
so if you look in that literature you
still see the stuff it's just the
interpretation and the theoretical
layering is so different what was the uh
justification for it what was their
interpretation of that effect
um you know it really wasn't
interpretation it was a sociological
study it was mainly to see what if what
is out there they really didn't have an
interpretation it was basically what if
but the what if aligns with behavior
genetic and evolution and psychological
interpretations
damn right it does which is why we're
interested in it Nancy you mentioned
there just you said about
um the study that you've done
is your study one of the biggest or the
biggest in terms of twins or is that
Robert bloman's study that he did in the
UK yeah Minnesota study yes oh no the
Minnesota study is not my study I worked
on it for many years and I still work on
it that was Dr Thomas Bouchard the
director who actually launched that now
keep in mind that was a weirdo part
study so we ended up with 137 pairs yep
for more identicals and fraternals
Plowman study is twins raised together
and he has thousands of pairs so
definitely going to have more yeah I
think it was every every set of twins
born in the UK between like 1991 and
1994 or something right it's something
like that it's something like that and
and those kinds of data sets are
remarkable
but I will tell you honestly Chris that
there's nothing I like more than being
in the lab with twins and seeing it up
close and personal because you really
see your data in action and I think
there's no substitute for that and I
remember at one of the international
twin congresses which are held every two
years I organized a film session where I
showed films about different aspects of
twinship and I remember some people
coming up to me and saying they loved
seeing this because all they do is work
with data and you know I work with data
too A lot of it but I also work with the
real human stuff
and when I bring twins into the lab I
just love it because again just by
acting naturally these twins give you
all kinds of new interesting ideas and
new takes on human development
did you watch the Netflix documentary
tell me who I am
no I didn't Nancy you must watch this
I'm writing it down now you must watch
it for the people that haven't seen it
it is I I wonder is this the one I think
it's some of the identical twin men and
they had a secret
is this the one yeah they have a secret
they one of the guys loses his memory
and then he has to be right I did see it
I did see it yes and it's remarkable I I
didn't know that I couldn't remember
that was the title but yes I do see that
it's remarkable yeah for the people I
won't spoil it um but for the people who
are interested in this uh three
identical strangers absolutely fantastic
film
um uh born together read apart your book
uh awesome awesome breakdown of this and
then that uh that tell me who I am is
harrowing and you see you see what got
me thinking about it was you saying when
you're in the lab and you see the Twins
and so on and so forth and um yeah on
this tell me who I am you see these guys
reveal this lifelong secret to each
other yeah on set and it's the first
time it's ever happened it is
yeah it was remarkable it was crazy it
was a film that we talked about for a
long time and and I will say there's
another film about the Louise wise
adoption agency that I think is also
excellent called the twinning reaction
which didn't get as much attention as
the others it was made by Laurie
Shinseki an independent filmmaker they
came out just about a year before three
identical strangers also very excellent
and many of the twins are in are in both
films you know when you think about
naturalistic observations one of the
best films I've ever seen was done on 16
millimeter back in the 60s by my thesis
advisor at the University of Chicago and
what he did was he filmed
identical and fraternal twins once a
month over the first year of life and he
looked at their reactions to strangers
so in every month he'd show them with
their mother where they're happy and
playing with a stranger and maybe with
this new toy and how they reacted to
that and I'm telling you it was
remarkable because the identicals were
so coordinated at young age fraternals
were so different it was amazing it's a
beautiful film and I wish more people
would do film it's this is something
that came up with the conference I was
at just last week the international
society for human ethology in Detroit
and it's a shame that more people don't
use film it really is it you can look at
it so many times and get new ideas and
it's it's it tells things in a way that
text just can't
Nancy Siegel ladies and gentlemen Nancy
I absolutely love your energy I love
your passion for your work I'm very very
glad that you came up to me at hbess and
and accosted me to one side and uh I've
been looking forward to speaking to you
for ages and I'm super super excited to
see what you do next where should people
go if they're interested in the work
that you're doing what books should they
start with and and what ones have you
got coming out and all the rest of it
yeah so I have a website with all my
twin books and one of my related
material and that is Doctor Dr Nancy
Siegel so
d-r-n-a-n-c-y-s-e-g-a-l-twins.org and I
update it very very often and I have
eight books out now my ninth one is
coming out in August that's gay fathers
twin Sons the citizenship case that
captured the world they might want to
look at my photo book on the Holocaust
twins there's a lot of interesting
stories about twinship in there
and deliberately divided certainly
deliberately divided uh Twins and
triplets adopted apart inside the Inside
Story something like that
um but but if you're really really new
to twin studies you might want to check
my 1999 book called entwined lies where
I cover many many different topics on
twins I cover the biology the psychology
uh
reproductive interests legal cases I I
work as a an expert witness on on legal
cases wrongful death injury custody all
kinds of things like that very very
fascinating and right now
um I'm gonna be on leave for a year and
I'm developing a new book proposal which
is going to be kind of a comprehensive
book kind of the the Tome on twin
studies so I'm excited about it yeah
very cool Nancy I appreciate the heck
out of you thank you very much for
joining me today thank you Chris I'm
glad I accosted you if you enjoyed that
episode then press here for a selection
of the best clips from the podcast over
the last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe